hello everyone and welcome to a video I
did not think I'd be making anytime soon
it's a former World Chess Championship
challenger Fabiano Khurana versus the
first ever chess playing chorus far as I
know Tesla Model 3 and before we check
out the game I would just like to
mention that this game is also available
and Fabiano kuranes youtube channel I
also did not know he had one so far he
had only one video on it but I will put
a link in the description below with
this exact game being played so you can
watch it firsthand if you also want to
check that out and also I would I will
have two very important announcements at
the end of this video so you know don't
miss out on that now getting back to the
game Khurana vs. car have Fabi opens
with E 4 and Tesla replies with the g6
the modern defense we have d4 d6 and now
Knight to c3 and test lock goes will now
transpose into the main line of the pr2
defense with F 4 Bobby does not hesitate
to go for the Austrian attack and Bishop
to g7 Tesla F in Cato's the dark square
Bishop Knight to f3 and now Tesla just
castles and for those of you who are
wondering which engine is Tesla running
not the one that actually makes the car
go but the one that runs the chest
I have no idea but we are going to
revisit this question after we check out
the game and Fabi immediately goes for
e5 so now the main idea is 97 and as you
will see if you watch for this video he
was very surprised when Tesla decided to
capture on e5 as you know practice has
shown on all four engines confirmed that
this doesn't really give black anything
with F captures on e5 now threatening
the knight Knight to d5 and the d le h4
fob is now ready to push h5 and start an
attack against Tesla's King and this row
was already tried in 2010 in world blitz
championship Hikaru Nakamura tried it
against flooding Mir Kramnik but Kramnik
was able to win that game so Tesla
replies with Knight captures on c3
gets rid of one of the Knights B
captures on c3 and now Queen to d5 there
is one game in the database for Bishop
to g4 was played but it doesn't really
help black hole that much with the h5
issue because even if you capture white
will gladly give up the rook here and
then
95 go after they spawn with the Queen
and the white will have an excellent
game so Tesla does not bother with the
idea with Queen to d5 and now Fabi goes
for h5 as h5 was not prevented with
Bishop to g4 now and now Paige captures
and g6 with F captures and g6 opening up
the F file for Tesla's rook and Fabi
defends the f3 square with Bishop 32
with Knight to c6 and now rook to be one
and just developing the rook - and I see
me open file with an attack against the
b7 pawn and Tesla could play something
like b6 your ooh k b8 but Tesla decides
to capture on a2 with Queen captures on
a 2 and now rook to b3 Bobby doesn't
like the idea of snatching the pawn here
but rather look to b3 preventing the
Queen from entering the game and also
now if a bee has some nasty ideas with
Bishop c4 check maybe rook captures on
h7 and a lot of things can happen here
so of course Tesla reacts to this with
Knights to a5 not only threatening to
capture the rook here but also keeping
an eye on the C 4 square so Bishop to c4
check is not possible with Knight to g5
by Caruana
and now like we said it's a bad idea to
capture the rook if you capture it
Bishop c4 is just deadly and just
deliver check and now if King h8 rook
captures on h7 is mating 1 and if you
don't capture if you play East 6 it's
not better Queen captures on d4 and
there's still a lot of problems here for
you to you know face so it would be a
very quick death for black Tesla of
course not interested in that
Tesla capture sunny - with Bishop
captures Queen captures and now not
capturing as it still doesn't work now
the Queen has access to the c-4 squares
so it's the same idea
so Queen to a-1 threatening to capture
the bishop on c1
tesla bobby'd replies with king to d1
now the king defends the bishop and here
it's interesting Tesla did not go for
capture the first time it could it
didn't go for capture the second time
but now it does best here for black is
rook a5 just threatening to capture here
because the bishop and c1 is pinned and
now even if you play something like rook
to a3 to now win the night here it's not
a problem Queen
one and I laughter white captures you
can capture on g5 white is still better
but the game continues however that's
not played Knight captures on b3 and now
I'm not even going to ask you to pause
the video because well you all see what
what's going to happen so congrats
congratulations everyone I'm not even
going to question whether all of you
found Quinta c4 check as I know we did
because now of course King h8 elites the
rook captures on h7 mate so Tesla of
course replied with east six but it
doesn't help Queen captures on e6 with
check rook to f7 Queen captures on f7
with check and now the only thing left
from black to do is play King to h8 and
here far we just played rook captures on
h7 and here it's a very nice checkmate
in 21 moves and if you think about it
this well setup here kind of does remind
you of the Tesla logo well at least me
so I think that's quite nice but yeah
really an exciting him and like I said I
don't know what engine Tesla runs and I
I think it I mentioned this on Twitter a
few days ago I thought it'd be really
cool if it didn't run like a classical
engine but a clean neural network that
you know gets stronger by each game that
is placed and all of the Tesla cars
should be communicating and making the D
neural networks stronger for example
Fabiano not Rose dries the Tesla magnet
across and also drives a Tesla so the
the the neural network would become
pretty strong if you know they play with
it a little bit but you know the more
people bought a Tesla you know you would
be not only saving the environment but
you will also make the car play better
chess which is just great you know two
of those things together or just awesome
but yeah that's pretty much for this
game and now I would just like to
mention the two announcements so yeah do
check out fabiana's video also feel free
to subscribe to this to his channel and
this also reminded me if you also have a
chess channel or maybe some other
channel that you feel people should be
aware of or you know that their vast
knowledge could be increased by by
following it I will put a an email in
the description below so feel free to
send me a link to this channel and I
will you know go through all of them
that you guys send me and
I will make a review of all of the
YouTube channels that you guys feel that
people should be aware of if maybe there
are small smaller channels so that's the
first part of the announcement and the
second part of the announcement sorry
about that I just have to open my door
there's someone at the door so I'll be
right back sorry about that
and the second part of the announcement
is that for those of you who are
interested in how the manga is doing the
manga is slowly progressing and for
those of you who want to be a part of it
from the beginning I will put a link to
my colleagues handle in the description
below it's a twitter handle so feel free
to follow him and you know as of
tomorrow he will be posting pretty much
everything he does not necessarily manga
related but whatever he draws sketches
has any ideas you're welcome to comment
on it you know
feel free to add on it maybe maybe you
want to be a part of it in some way so
you know I don't I'm just putting it out
there feel free to join us you know
maybe one day you can also be a part of
the team and we can create something
special maybe we'll see how it goes but
yeah that's the game a corona versus car
a very nice victory for the former world
chess championship Challenger I would
like to thank Chris Schneider Daniel
bond a proctor my know Michael Keane and
Jeremy means for contributing to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check too
in my previous video so you're thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the Capablanca saga of course
finally and checking up on your
suggestions as usual thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your weekend